l'idée encore une fois qu'il y aurait
finalement des minorités qui au sein de
la société française ferait peser un
danger sur la pérennité de cette de
cette dernière alors ça ça s'appelle de
manière très claire et on peut aussi
citer des définitions à n'en plus finir
et ça s'appelle typiquement des formes
de croyance en la conspiration
la théorie conspirationniste elle
transpire absolument des propos de la de
la ministre la théorie conspirationniste
elle transpire et aussi des propos d'
emmanuel macron aux mureaux comme l a
transpiré depuis quelques temps et
pendant plus de 200 heures à l'assemblée
nationale lorsque la loi sur les
séparatismes a été a été discuté donc
encore une fois ce sont des minorités en
particulier des groupes en particulier
pour être très clair ce sont des groupes
racisés qu'ils font à chaque fois
l'objet de tentative d'effacement de
tentatives de disqualification de
l'espace public et de tentatives de
disqualification des espaces de pouvoir
tels que l'université peut être un
espace de pouvoir donc c'est pour ça que
face à cette théorie conspirationniste
c'est important de souligner à chaque
fois à quel point il y à des perceptions
nationalistes des perceptions très
concentré et des perceptions grassi
amusante qui sont qui sont à l'heure
qu'ils sont profondément injuste puisque
elles viennent jeter le discrédit sur
des groupes profondément l'hétérogène
qui travaillent de manière extrêmement
diverses mais qui travaille toujours
encore une fois en se soumettant au
cadre méthodologique de l'université
donc on voit bien ici à quel poids en
mobilisant une sorte de méconnaissance
d'ignorance volontaire de ce qu'est
véritable université on rejette à
nouveau une partie à une partie des
chercheurs et une partie de leurs
recherches vers l'idée que cela
représenterait finalement le ventre mou
de l'islamisme et la fin probable de la
société voire de l'art de la deûle
empire français tel qu'il se présente
encore son odieux parfois
[Musique]